The newest additions to the Knit it
Now Basics patterns are sideways knits.
These styles are a refreshing change of
pace from your traditional hem to neck
knitting patterns, and they
offer new design possibilities.
The pieces are started at the arm hole.
For a sleeveless version,
you cast on and hang hem.
If you want sleeves,
cast on with waste yarn.
Next you'll work the side seams, shaped
or straight, whichever you prefer.
Lengthening and shortening this sweater
is a matter of adding or removing needles
because the sweater is
kn it from side to side.
Any horizontal stitch patterns
becomes slimming vertical details.
You can even add stripes for
more casual look to your sweater.
Pull over neck lines are simplified.
Unlike traditional sweater shapes, you
don't have to work the two sides of the
neck opening separately
and for cardigans, you don't have to
pick up and rehang the front bands.
Simply hang a hem and work button
holes to finish the center front.
To add sleeves, you would cast on at
your arm holes with waste yarn, knit your
fronts and backs.
Then join the shoulders, pick up your
sleeves and knit them down to the cuffs.
You can work some ribbing, hang a
hem and your sleeves are finished.
The hem of this sweater style
offers lots of possibilities.
One option is to simply
finish the hems with crochet.
But think about this.
Leave a needle out of work about an
inch or so in and create a fold line.
When your sweater's complete and you've
sewn up your side seams, simply fold up
the hem along this line
and stitch it in place.
You can pick up and knit some ribbing.
Another option is to add a peplum
to the bottom of the sweater.
You can also hang a band, just
a regular band on the hems.
We offer fitted versions of this sweater
with a four inch bottom band, and we also
have a no waist shaping
version of this sweater.
With the smaller hem,
are you starting to get inspired?
Consider a Basics sideways knit
sweater for your next project.